We always talk about market failure,
but we never talk about government failure and you could check some of these
boxes,
some of the horrific things that federal and state governments have done since
the beginning of this pandemic to screw up the food supply to you.
Remember this, this supposedly, uh, cache of, of, uh,
uh, N 95 masks, um, administration is going to have, well,
guess what government fails.
It always fails because politics is a horrible way to solve complex problems.
So when you combine those two things, if you're going to shut off the,
the ingenuity of free people to solve problems and replace it with a
central plan, that is by definition, going to be dysfunctional and wrong.
Um, that's where you get really, really bad things in our society.
Having you on now is sort of the perfect time because if Liberty ever needed
a jolt or if it ever was about to have a resurgence,
I think both of those things are sort of possible right now.
I sense that we need it more than ever, at least in modern times right now,
and that it could be on the cusp of really gaining momentum right now.
So give me your basic breakdown of sort of where we're at with
Corona, sort of what you thought we should have done. What,
what was the appropriate Liberty minded response say two months ago in this
first thing was, was rolling out to kind of where we are right now.
So my, my initial reaction and I went back and checked.
The first piece I wrote about the pandemic was I think,
March 16th. So it's a pretty early on.
I actually wrote it on a beach in Joest van.
I was on vacation and we had to cancel it to get back to the United States
before I was afraid they were going to close the airports and,
and me being a geek, I, I wrote this piece,
but I was worried that that centralized top-down one size fits
all solutions to very complex problems was,
was inevitably going to create a lot of unintended and destructive
consequences. And I was thinking about one of my economist heroes,
Frederick cost yachts, and, and he, he,
he talks about the seen and the unseen and the inability of people
to conceive of the, uh,
incredibly complex division of labor that brings food to your table everyday.
You don't know how it happened. And, and you can see that playing out now,
people just assumed that food would show up. And so when,
when grocery store shelves are empty, they start panicking and they, frankly,
they start blaming markets.
When in fact it was meddling into the market process that created that.
And so my not, not even conceiving that we would do these massive,
never ending lockdowns, the way that the governors did.
I was worried that we're,
that the government was going to do all of things that would make it more
difficult to deal with, not just the disease and the virus,
but all the other things we need to do to keep our families safe.
And one of those things is earning income. Another is put food on the table.
A third is, is actually being able to take care of yourself and go outside,
uh, maybe get cancer treatments and all these things that,
that are now proving impossible to do. So I, knowing that government fails,
I was afraid that they were going to fail colossally bad,
and that's kind of where we're at.
Okay. So I think most of my audience will be with you on the, okay.
We don't like the, the top down version of this.
We want to figure out sort of local level individual stuff. First,
what I see a lot of people on Twitter saying is, Oh,
this shows the flaw of libertarianism.
This shows the flaw of small government because in a time like this,
a pandemic knows no borders.
We need strong national decisions that are across the board and the rest of it.
How do you combat that?
Well, I think, um, the entire purpose of the market process,
and I call it a mutual support system,
the entire purpose of people getting together and cooperating and
trading and engaging in ideas is,
is because we live in a radically uncertain world.
What happened yesterday is in no way tells us what's going to happen tomorrow.
And the whole point for that process is for people to figure out really complex
things that are going to happen to us. And it feels like this exoticness shock,
this natural disaster of a global pandemic is exactly what you want a
decentralized system to solve and add top on that,
how much government officials don't know, we always talk about market failure,
but we never talk about government failure.
And you could check some of these boxes,
some of the horrific things that federal and state governments have done since
the beginning of this pandemic to screw up the food supply to you.
Remember this, this supposedly, uh, cache of, of, uh,
uh, N 95 masks, um, administration is going to have, well,
guess what government fails.
It always fails because politics is a horrible way to solve complex problems.
So when you combine those two things, if you're going to shut off the,
the ingenuity of free people to solve problems and replace it with a central
plan, that is by definition, going to be dysfunctional and wrong. Um,
that's where you get really, really bad things in our society.
Do you sense that a lot of the divide on the people that view the world
top-down versus the people that view the world bottom up,
that it's just a fundamental psychological conditioning that they
have, that it's not just, Oh, we learned we have different economic policies,
let's say, but that their fear centers are, or, you know, I find when I,
when I hear all the big government people,
they S they seem to have this trust in a thing just because the thing
exists. So it's sort of inherently must be good because it existed,
or maybe 50 years ago it was better or something like that.
Versus I think people more in line with our thinking where it's like, well,
just because it exists doesn't mean it's inherently good.
So I want to just scale the power back. Do you think that how much,
a certain amount of this is just your psychological makeup? You know.
That, and, um, not to,
not to sort of castigate my progressive friends, but, but I think,
um,
people don't appreciate just how much we don't know as
individuals and how much our leaders don't know,
even though they went to all the right colleges and have all of these
Prudentials. And so maybe it's a, it,
there's a line in the sand about humility and being willing to say in
public, uh,
what is this new pandemic and how does it compare to past pandemics and what
don't we know, um, if some of these modelers would have said, you know what,
there's no way that I could model this in an honest way.
So let me tell you the things that we do know,
but let me also tell you that if I project numbers,
there's no way it's going to be right. It's always going to be wrong. And,
and that sort of goes back to the old dream of,
of progressivism that you could take science and science was settled and really
smart people that went to the right colleges could take that science and impose
it on the rest of us.
And we would have this sort of rationally planned top-down society,
but that lacks humility. It lacks any sense that,
that you couldn't possibly know enough to plan a complex economy. And this was,
this was Frederick Hayek's entire critique of, of socialist planning.
And I think it applies to, to any would be planner, even,
even some of the, some of the governors and how they're they're,
they're telling us all in a very micro, cosmic way,
like you should do this and you shouldn't do that. Yeah.
We talked about this a little bit when I was on your show a couple of weeks ago,
but do you think some of this sort of also is just the end of secularism
in a weird way? It's the end of just, Oh,
people just creating systems in the moment that aren't necessarily experts and
that the experts get everything wrong and that we just keep sort of outsourcing
all of our decision-making and every day we wake up and as you're saying
yesterday, doesn't, doesn't really, uh, form what tomorrow will be.
And that we've just sort of hit the end of what we can build in a
weird way. Some, something like that.
Yeah. Like there's, there's definitely been this, uh,
democratization and decentralization disintermediation.
My wife hates it when I use that word,
because it doesn't mean anything to anybody, but, um, technology has,
has democratized knowledge and information.
And I happened to be one of those guys that was super romantic about the
potential to decentralize everything based on that. Um,
but it seems like there's a backlash now and,
and you have clickbait and you have censorship and you have all of
these things where sort of the,
the empire striking back to get back to that phase.
I knew he to get there,
the experts do not like the fact that,
that we probably don't need to go to school to, to figure out, uh,
electrical engineering.
We probably don't need to defer to epidemiologists because we could
actually do some of that research for ourselves and discover that there is
patterns and there is history and, and all that stuff is available to us.
So I think in a lot of ways,
the backlash by the planners is because we were,
we were actually needing them less and they see an opportunity right
now to reconsolidate power and take it back.
And for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.